hello my name is totally not mark and I
love Dragon Ball super or TBS if you're
hip and with-it fam but listen here you
me homeboy I've spent more time reading
and watching Dragonball than my parents
has been regretting sending me to
college but I offer you purveyor of this
fine Internet diner if you are perhaps
someone you are familiar with do require
assistance in familiarizing oneself with
the cause the maze or dare I say at the
Haas I've decided to serve up a
handy-dandy beginner's guide for all
those would-be hashtag real fans
what are we word for anyone can watch it
and it makes you feel good Dragon Ball
super is a show that sometimes reads as
though it was hastily ad-libbed by a
hungover kindergarten teacher during
story time this is the highest
compliment of which I am capable Dragon
Ball super makes you feel like a kid
again
and kids are idiots when I was five I
used to sneak out of the shower naked
and run as fast as I could out the front
door of my house and down the street at
the time I thought it was hilarious 18
years later a doctor would diagnose me
with ADHD but don't let my youthful
anecdotes pry you from Dragon Ball super
tantalizing gaze Dragon Ball super is
not targeted towards any one group of
body pillow enthusiasts specifically
however I will say if you haven't seen
Dragon Ball Dragon Ball Z or anything by
Akira Toriyama I'm gonna give you the
same advice porn actresses receive on
their first day get on that one
this ain't your grandma's anime Dragon
Ball super is what many in the biz call
a gateway show it's easy to watch and
there are almost no awkward Japanese
isms even my dad used to watch a little
dragon ball back in the day he's the
kind of man who only watches golf and
other such sporting related activities I
wasn't good at any of those maybe he
only watched dragon ball at a futile
attempt at making a connection with his
pathetic shutting of us so there are
tons of wacky new characters Dragon Ball
super invites us all to enjoy these
wonderful new additions to the story
beerus is a humanoid cat that loves food
that's hilarious
how many twins they decide to make the
same joke over the course of 31 episodes
it might be of interest to some of my
more observant viewers to know that
beerus despite his feline features seems
to be inundated with a number of
reptilian and specifically snake-like
statue structures this is due to his
initial conceptualization being centered
around a slithery scaly design
I wish very much to see said design I
want to show more wheeze is an angel
that has taken the form of a blue tall
and metrosexual Japanese Hollister model
from the future shadow the hedge I mean
Goku black a time-traveling angsty teen
taking the form of Goku hell bent on
murdering literally everyone while going
to what must be tremendous effort in
wearing exclusively off black clothing
subarashii and jeering a beefed up grey
alien who is best friends with a
moustache older characters have changed
Vidal has changed a whole bunch
she married Gohan had a child named
after bread and has no interest in
fighting anymore I guess they have that
in common too the Buu saga takes place
over the course of two days of the story
the delegates to cute hairstyles in that
time Dragon Ball super spans a number of
years yet Fidel's hair Fester's in the
same classic soccer-mom hairstyle the
entire time her kid doesn't even play
soccer
he removed ho GAE Farnam ation Bulnes
had so many heck and hairstyles that
some cool person thought it necessary to
make a two part blog spread chronicling
bulnes carefully crafted cuts wow she
looks like a boy in this world Dragon
Ball super is hella chill bro for no
reason other that neither of us had seen
it and it seemed like a weird idea at
the time myself and my friend decided to
watch Schindler's List
comparatively Dragon Ball super is a
pretty chill time I'm a fan of that I
used to wake up on a Sunday grab a
bucket of delicious Kellogg Special K
cereal snuggle up and for a
light-hearted fun adventure with my
favorite 40 year old serial killer sorry
Ryan Reynolds watching Dragon Ball super
will not teach you Japanese I lived in
Japan for two months and despite having
seen literally thousands of Dragonball
episodes in Japanese no less to my
surprise when I arrived none of the
locals had the common decency to speak
with subtitles I can only assume this
was racially charged aggression in any
case I consistently struggled to recall
even a fraction of how to ask where the
bathroom was one time I purchased a one
liter carton of yogurt instead of milk
it made my delicious Kellogg's Special K
cereal decisively undelicious oops but
no use crying over spilled yogurt in
fact know that I'm thinking about a
strong case could be made that watching
Dragon Ball super actively made my
Japanese worse than it already was it's
in English and Japanese
delicioso watching sub and dub fans
interact is like watching two people who
believe the other is a flat earther and
try hard as they might they cannot begin
to fathom just how this other person
could ever hold what is so clearly a
wrong opinion or how they in fact tied
their own shoes that morning being
expected to read subtitles can be a
difficult enterprise for children under
the age of seven or the blind especially
blind children under the age of seven
but it's also understandable if one
wants to relax to enjoy their show of
choice with the characters speaking the
godbless in american language however my
double choice is the original Japanese
version it's the version that presents
the characters most faithfully and does
not make Goku utter bro phraseology like
man and or dude however I choose this
version not for the aforementioned
reason I couldn't care less what matter
the insane jargon is thrust upon me by
these glorified ventriloquist dummies I
mean no disrespect to voice actors
though they think it's an admirable
profession having grown up a Content
starved part of the 90s my upbringing
has forged a patience akin to a hungry
sea go looking at a pile of rotten
the thought should I wait never crosses
my mind I'm never not going to take the
fastest option I'm not a psychopath the
first time I ever saw the Japanese
version off Dragonball though was when
my friend loaned me the freezer arc off
Dragon Ball Z that he got from his
grandpa on VHS this specifically was
weird to me because the only thing my
grandpa ever gave me was an acute fear
of being tickled and a genetic
predisposition to bone cancer Taub sub
what even are words anyway most of them
don't even make sense we don't cook
cookies do we we bake them they should
be called bay keys I can't be the only
one that thinks this Dragon Ball super
is popular to claim Dragon Ball super
made a lot of money in 2018 is as
emphatic an understatement to saying
delicious Kellogg's special-case cereal
made a lot of money in 2018 from my
wallet I want that so move the show is
very popular however very few other less
stagnated laser-focused channels outside
of the molten-hot cesspit of the Dragon
Ball fandom dare making single video
discussing the show in any meaningful
capacity less they experienced the wrath
of these keyboards Z warriors for any
inaccuracies or opposing opinions they
may have regarding this beloved
children's cartoon series the community
is welcoming like a cult
Dragon Ball has a thriving online
presence and community the best part
about being a Dragon Ball find in 2018
is that you no longer have to guess the
answers to questions you had about
Dragon Ball it's the future I ask my
questions on Twitter the responses are
many and immediate Wow however if you
are not like me don't get paid
inexplicably to talk about Dragon Ball
and haven't cultivated a following that
stemmed from a series of videos using
the specific information of a younger
more handsome British boy don't sweat it
Jim because the Dragon Ball online
community has options for you why not
try to integrate yourself into the
friendly hustle and bustle of a Twitter
thread or youtube comment section it's
many of these discussions are centered
around the same few things
who can punch harder team forced air
quotes and advanced animation theory
pertain to digital and traditional
mediums but be wary if you say something
that someone might disagree with you
must then ready yourself for an
onslaught akin to a rabid grizzly bear
attack and just like a mama grizzly must
protect her cubs so to do nerds need to
defend their opinions viciously I deal
with this by disabling notification
everyone knows everything about
animation always when I first began
watching Dragon Ball super
I had a sobering wave of disappointment
cascade over my cereal filled cheeks the
great episode 5 Fiasco of 2015 claimed
many a nostalgia goggle however it was
then I discovered Dragon Ball super is
greatest attributes complaining about
Dragon Ball super I found a way to
monetize it but before you go belching
out your distaste for the modern Asiatic
aesthetic you should keep in mind that
shockingly and incredibly the Dragon
Ball fandom has become the only group I
can think of in history that sometimes
sounds like they know what they're
talking about when it comes to animation
it's so convincing even I don't
understand what they're talking about
sometimes and I studied animation for
years Dragon Ball super is really
colorful and edgy the world of Dragon
Ball super is pretty vibrant it's like a
coral reef hug the saturation Bart oh
the humanity the characters are so shiny
everything that has a pulse in the show
looks like a freshly glazed ham
delicious if you like thought there was
too much blood in Dragon Ball Z and that
Dragon Ball super got rid of it to
appease all those displeased mothers
they don't trip Home Slice
this ain't no anime for babies ya dig so
reprobates out there might claim that
there's no blood and Dragon Ball super
but fret not my blood curdling brethren
my calculations have it averaging about
one blood stain every forty three
episodes wow that's almost one blood
scene every nine months take that
approximate gestational periods and I'm
not even talking about those wimpy red
scratches you get from falling off your
mom's tricycle
oh no I'm talking gallons of that
gushing hemoglobin goodness in
conclusion Dragon Ball super puts the BS
in dB
the BS stands for best show so check it
out champ also if you leave a like in
this video and subscribe and hit the
bell icon I'll give you a bake thank you
so much for watching bye
[Music]